Bonjour.
Pour commencer je citerais Patrick Sébastien qui disait :
Une petite pipe avant de se coucher, un petit calumet de la paix.
Aujourd'hui je reçois Jean-Hubert Huler, Jean-Hubert, bonjour.
Bébert.
Donc vous êtes l'homme le plus Beauf du monde, c'est bien ça ?
Ouais si tu le dis.
Bébert,
comment, devient-on Beauf, justement ?
Hein ?
Comment devient-on Beauf ?
Je comprends pas.
Ah ok, pardon.
Comment que c'est qu'on devient Beauf ?
Ah ! Mais tu t'exprimes mal aussi.
Ben c'est un état d'esprit que c'est nous qu'on comprend mieux.
Que c'est nous qu'on comprend quoi.
L'état d'esprit.
Ok, y a une personne qui a été la première à remarquer que vous étiez Beauf ?
Ouais, le truc qui parle.
Je vois pas.
Si avec les nibards.
Votre femme ?
Voilà, la gonzesse.
Vous êtes fier d'être Beauf ?
Un peu mon neveu !
Admettons, des détracteurs rentrent dans la salle et vous disent les Beaufs c'est nul.
Qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez ?
Les détracteurs ça rentre pas dans la salle, c'est super gros.
Et je vois les portes elles sont super petites,
ou alors à la limite on pète les roues ou alors on pète le mur,
Mais alors faut savoir que si c'est un mur porteur,
Comment on fait pour savoir si c'est un mur porteur, on tape, ça fait toc toc,
Ok c'est super, vraiment merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage.
Je sais.
On va faire plutôt un test Beauf pour évaluer votre niveau, vous êtes daccord ?
C'est parti mon kiki.
Pour vous un homme aux cheveux long c'est quoi ?
Un PD.
Qu'est-ce que vous regardez en premier ?
Les nibards.
Qu'est-ce que vous attendez d'un chef d'état ?
Des nibards.
Votre chanteur préféré ?
Philippe Rizzoli.
Non, non, votre chanteur préferé.
Joli.
Votre plat préféré ?
La bière !
Vous avez des enfants ?
Ouais, Yvon et Jacques.
Ah, ben c'est pas si Beauf.
Yvon et Jacques Huler !
Ah si !
Votre livre préféré ?
L'Équipe.
Votre blague préférée ?
C'est effectivement très marrant.
Merci, c'est bon.
Stop !
Voilà, on a compris.
Voilà stop.
Stop.
Ok stop.
Stop ! Stop ! Stop là ! Ça va on a compris, oui !
C'est ce que je dis depuis le début, vous êtes un pauvre type enfermé dans votre vie triste là !
Vous savez quoi ? J'ai pitié de vous !
Voilà...
Elle est super bien ma vie moi !
Ah bon ?
Moi je pars en vacances, en famille dans le camping.
Tu pars en vacances toi ?
J'ai fait les volcans d'Auvergne avec mon père une fois.
Ben moi je fais les barbeucs avec les copains.
T'as des copains toi ?
Oui, c'est les copains de mon père.
Voilà.
Qui c'est qu'a une vie de merde ?
Ben c'est moi...Voilà.
Je suis rongé de névroses, j'ai mes peurs qui me bouffent tout les jours un peu plus c'est pour ça que ma femme m'a quitté.
J'ai un boulot de merde et je suis pas épanoui. Voilà.
Vous avez voulu gratter, vous avez trouvé.
La semaine prochaine nous recevrons l'homme le plus indécis du monde.
Ah non !
Si pardon.
Non.
Si en fait.
C'est, c'est annulé.
Ah non  !
Hé si !
Ah non !
Pas dispo !